senator Bernie Sanders calls president
Trump's proposed budget morally
repugnant in a USA Today opinion piece
and includes deep cuts at the Department
of Education but supporters of the move
say the nine a billion dollar rollback
we'll put the Department on a
much-needed diet Michelle Miller visited
a successful after-school program in New
Jersey that relies on federal funds to
survive Michelle good morning good
morning the proposed budget cuts would
terminate a nationwide after-school
program known as 21st century Community
Learning Centers there are currently
more than ninety five hundred of these
centers across the country and they can
be found in every state we went to a
school district in New Jersey where
administrators say it's not only working
but there's a waiting list to enroll as
the school day ends in Plainfield New
Jersey
most students head home but about 350 of
them take to the cafeterias gyms and
classrooms for a federally funded
after-school program known as 21st
century Community Learning Center's we
align what we do to the school day to
support school day teachers but with
after-school and summer learning
opportunities we can really hone in on
our instructional craft and be more
innovative Zelda Spence is the director
of the program in Plainfield almost 100
percent of our 21st century after school
students graduate high school and obtain
either a vocation or go on to college
and graduate and they wouldn't have if
they hadn't had this program it would be
highly difficult our children here
struggle many of our families are
economically compromised and we're able
to provide opportunities that their
parents just don't have the money to be
able to do if you lose this funding what
would that mean to this district it
would be devastating for us brothers
Josue and Joelle Cordova spend
afternoons here while their parents are
at work for these are your boys yes
there are moms who Lika met us on her
lunch hour to boast about their
accomplishments I seen a lot of change
for my kids with
Academy porn I got all A's I was like
mom I got all A's and I sent you a
picture did she believe you picture of
the green for Alma claim success here in
Plainfield National results of the 21st
century Community Learning Center's have
been less encouraging according to the
Department of Education most recent
evaluation of the program in 2014 just
over a third of students participating
saw improvement in math and English
grades that fall short of the target to
improve grades for nearly half of its
students who participate it's a program
that has really failed to meet its
stated mission Lindsey Burke is the
director of education policy for the
Heritage Foundation a conservative think
tank based in Washington DC even beyond
the evidence on the program or the lack
of evidence about its effectiveness we
have to ask whether this is
appropriately housed at the federal
level and is it really appropriate for
the federal government to be funding
after-school programs and I think that
the answer to that question is no 21st
century Community Learning Center's were
created in 1994 under President Bill
Clinton then expanded in 2001 under
president george w bush it serves more
than 2 million people each year on an
annual budget of 1.2 billion dollars
what should we do five hundred and fifty
thousand of that goes to the Plainfield
New Jersey School District federal
funding that drops to zero in president
Trump's current budget proposal is there
any way the district could fund this
program without those federal dollars it
would be challenging of course we can
look to Wright and obtain competitive
grant funding opportunities but that is
not a guarantee and sacrificing the
healthy and so very important learning
experiences for children it just doesn't
seem
worth it to me the billion-dollar cuts
to the 21st Century Learning Center's
are about the same amount President
Trump is proposing to offer to charter
schools in his budget Plainfield has
five charter schools which
administrators say helped create a more
than eight million dollar deficit in the
district and that will make funding this
after-school program locally a real
challenge you know a lot of critics say
you know charter schools are judged by
the best of them well this is a
situation where you have locally these
these after-school programs that make a
difference I think the issue is scaling
up mm-hmm
nobody denies the difference that they
make for the better listen he's talking
about he got all A's on his report now I
know that's always a good thing yeah no
easy answer is either no no and when you
see improvement you have to reward it
where it is gotcha Thank You Michelle
thank you very much